look at this
hit it
oh [__] come on
[Applause]
holy [__]
oh
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god wait wait wait wait kiss hans
again
[Applause]
oh my god hans is like don't let him
talk to you like that
i'll protect you
they are just making out
you sue by the way tons cam everybody
isabella thank you so much
isabella
isabella take one of those just for oh
wow
[Music]
yeah wait oh
hold on
hold on stop stop stop
yes
[Applause]
[Music]
yes oh
[__] dude
[Music]
oh my god
wow that is abs han's date came to an
abrupt end just now oh [__]
yeah
oh my god
wait what about that one
[Music]
[Applause]
oh [__]
wow
[Laughter]
good god oh my god
you have to make out with hans too if
you want to come up here
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
actual girl
oh [__]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh [__]
[Applause]
[Music]
this is incredible hey what about the
other girl what about the other girl
wait what about this one
far away on the far way
yikes
oh my god he's still going
oh my god
he's getting he's gonna kiss them all on
their way out
[Applause]
[Music]
oh my god
wow
[Music]
[Applause]
professional
come on guys make some noise hans kim
living his dreams
[Applause]
oh my god jesus christ
oh my god for a second because i yeah
oh my god
april
oh [__] that's a real girl whoa
damn
[Music]
that's not even one of the yellow rose
red rose girls
that's a real that's a real girl here
you go
show the audience what you got kiss me
another face wow
damn look at that
[Laughter]
[Music]
holy [__]
oh [__] these are real girls
kiss me
oh my god look at this
[Applause]
whoa that one
look at that one
this better be a real make-out session
though
whoa
wow
look at him go
oh there's some
hans an unbelievable performance a great
song
[Applause]
wait a second
hold on just a minute
wait a second whoa